Hello, everyone. This is
Pediatric Considerations in
Hematology and Oncology.
I am Dr. Thomas Chan. Here
is my email. If you need
to contact me, my pointer
works. And let's get going.
We have a lot to cover.
Hematology and oncology
within one hour is
difficult, but we'll try
to give you the big points.
Think clinically. That's
really what I'm after.
It's really recognizing
the condition and just the
pertinent points, the most
important points in terms of
history, physical, and maybe
some aspects of treatment.
But you'll be able to
get a sense of what
I think is important.
Obviously, these
are the session
objectives. They're pretty
self-explanatory. A lot
of conditions, especially
hematology. Kids do have a
lot of hematologic issues. A
lot of it is genetic, but
we can't cover everything.
Many, many of these conditions
you have encountered
already in other lectures
or will encounter.
We'll just talk about,
you know, again, pediatric
related aspects of it where
you would have gotten a
lot of these conditions,
you know, in adult lectures
or pathology and things
like that. But I'll try to
give you the pediatric
spin, which is why I'm here.
All right, so when do you
suspect anemia in pediatrics?
obviously the hemoglobin
is low right so why do
you get the hemoglobin
sometimes you suspect it because
they're pale uh they feel
weak tired uh you might
sometimes hear flow murmur
so it's very common when
you do learn cardio next
year um you know when you're
anemic your body's going
to want to you know your
heart's going to pump a
little bit harder to kind of
get uh more blood flowing
throughout the body and
sometimes you can hear these
this flow murmurs from it
right kids can have normal
murmurs in general, but
sometimes you do find that
out from them being anemic.
Sometimes you're just
getting CBCs for screening.
We do screen children
very commonly when they're
very young because the
most high-risk time for
anemia is when they're
one to two years of age.
So sometimes you pick
it up from there, right?
Sometimes they're having
more red flags, such
as you know, they're
actually like getting
really short of breath,
very weak. They might
even like look like
they're going to pass out.
So syncope is very,
very common, where they
stand up quickly, and
then they get very
dizzy. And sometimes
they pass out, obviously
going to do a workup
when that happens.
You know, a theme of this
lecture is going to be
knowing the red flags in
pediatrics, practical pediatrics
is, you know, when that
you might want to suspect
that we could be dealing
with something worse, right?
Significant issue, not
just iron deficiency
anemia, which is
the most common. All
right. So things like
bone pain, chronic
problems, hemolysis
leading to jaundice,
right? So children
should not be jaundiced
after, you know, outside
the newborn period.
that's not normal, right? So if
you detect have
had a spenomegaly,
lymphadenopathy, like
lots of lymph nodes all
around, or they have
persistent systemic complaints,
feeling very tired,
chronic fever, weight loss,
right? So again, there's
a prolonged issue going on.
And sometimes you do have
to listen to the parents
when parents say they've
been really not looking
well for about a month, just
sleeping all the time,
doesn't want to play. Playing
is a big thing, right? Kids
always want to play. We
always want to play, but
kids really love to play.
And if they're not playing,
that's a problem, right?
Fever, kids also get
fever commonly, but fevers
usually don't last more
than three to five days in a
row. When they last longer
than that, you start
thinking, could there be
something else going on, okay?
An initial workup, obviously
CBC, is very common to
get a reticulocyte count
and a ferritin level for
the stores of the iron,
right? So the reticulocyte
count is a good measure of
how active the bone marrow
is, right? Right. So I
always think of it like a
factory. Right. So you're
going to hear that analogy
during this time where
the factory produces its
products. Right. In this
case, platelets, white cells
and red cells. OK. So when
the factory is humming
along, your reticulocyte
count will be normal
because this factory is
working at a normal rate. If
you need to increase
production for whatever reason,
you know, then your
reticulocyte count will
go up. right? If the
factory shuts down
for some reason, such
as COVID happened,
all factories shut down
because, you know, no one
could go to work and the
whole world's in lockdown,
right? If you did a reticocycle,
it would be low, right?
So one other physical exam
finding most people don't
realize is you can look
underneath the eye or the
mucous membranes. So skin,
obviously you look at
pallor, but you know, we
have different skin tones, so
it could be a little tricky,
but the eyes, you know
the mucous membranes don't
lie so you can actually see
it right and there are
some old school doctors and
when on a global health
trip uh you know the doctors
didn't have access to lab
work for most of the patients
they would just always
be looking into his kid's
eye and oh that's normal
that's probably 11 they'd
be like look at another
kid oh that's like 8.5 i'm
like okay i mean no one would
know if they're right or
wrong because we never got
a cbc but he seemed really
confident when he said
those things all right so a
very common pediatric
condition is called physiologic
nadir, or the physiologic
anemia of infancy. So
what we call physiologic
means is normal, basically,
right? So once they're born,
they take a deep breath,
tons of oxygen comes into
the body. And what happens
because of that, the
body just kind of calms
down and the bone marrow
hasn't woken up yet, right?
The baby's bone marrow
hasn't woken up, didn't
need to wake up yet
because mom was providing
everything through the
placenta, right? So because of
that, it takes a while
before the factories, the
baby's factories to kind
of get going, right? So
the erythropoietin is on
a low level and it slowly
takes a little while to
ramp up. In the meantime,
the hemoglobin, when the
baby's first born, is at its
highest because mom gave
him or her enough blood,
and it slowly goes down
over the next six to eight
weeks until the bone marrow
can start coming up. So
usually by around three
months, three to four months,
everything's back to
normal. Now, we rarely check
babies for anything at
this time, and it's usually
something you just end up
finding. They happen to be in
the hospital because of a
fever, rule out sepsis. they
realize that baby's anemic.
So you have to understand
this thing. So you
understand, don't go crazy.
You don't have to do too
much. You don't have to start
iron or transfusions. It's
probably a physiological
anemia of infancy, and we
call it a day, all right?
This one is a little bit
more scarier because it's
of childhood, right?
Transient erythroblastopenia
of childhood. So we're
dealing with older kids,
not newborn periods in
around the six to eight week
mark, right? And what
happens is that for some
reason, the factory's going
along, child's growing up,
normal weight, normal
development, everything's
good. And in some
reason, that part of the
factory that makes red
cells just goes to sleep.
Just goes to sleep. And
what happens is that the
hemoglobin just slowly comes
down. Now, it happens very,
very slowly, and the child
may start getting some
symptoms, looking a little
more pale, being a little
more tired. um and then um
but uh and we don't know and
reticulocyte if you did a
reticulocyte count it would
be low right but again
it's a previously healthy
child right a lot of times
they had a viral illness in
the previous uh and what
probably happened was the
virus came into the body
and shut down it didn't shut
down the whole factory but
it kind of affected that
one part of the that produces
red cells okay so you
slowly develop pallor and
you slowly recover all right
so i had one patient who
had this uh was sent to the
the hematologist not by me
uh they just went on their
own was doing like the
mega million dollar workup
uh got so much blood work
over time they like every
test under sun and i was
really telling him like i
think it's just transient
retroblastopenia The child
looks great. There were no
red flags, absolutely none.
No chronic bone pain,
no hepatic spynomegaly.
This is the most normal,
healthy-looking kid you
can have. No petechiae
that makes you think that
the other parts of the bone
marrow are not working,
like the platelets or
the white cell count.
No signs of hemolysis.
Everything looked
good, and it really
was. you know, over the
course of several
months, everything came
down and everything
came back up. All right.
All right. So iron deficiency
anemia, by far the
most common thing.
I actually put a note to
myself and I was going
to put a pic of a chubby
baby drinking lots of
milk, but I never got around
to making the, getting
the picture. All right.
So what it is, is that
obviously if you have
low iron stores because
you're ********* or low
birth weight, that's going
to make you more likely
have iron deficiency.
But most times, it's
a nutritional issue.
And what happens is
that they have excessive
milk intake, especially
in this country.
A lot of babies love,
parents love giving
their babies milk. Babies
love drinking milk.
And milk actually doesn't
have a lot of iron
in it. It's got other
nutrients, and they
grow. And what it is,
they pick a chubby baby
because all the milk
they're drinking, so they'll
be drinking 40, 50
ounces of milk a day.
tons of milk.
And they sometimes actually
all the extra milk can
actually cause micro bleeding
in the GI tract, right?
Not to the point where you
see blood in the stools,
but they leak a little bit
blood here and there. And
that's another source of
iron loss. So they're not
getting a lot of iron in and
they're losing some through
the GI tract. And if you're
drinking so much milk,
you're full. So you're so
full, you don't want to
eat all the other foods,
all the broccoli, the peas,
the meats, and things
like that. Another common
reason is GI bleeding,
which is not common
in kids, but a very
common thing is adolescent
girls having very heavy
menses, losing iron.
So a very common thing
is low hemoglobin. You
usually have a low MCV,
so you're looking at
the classic microcytic
hypochromic, right? I
think you know that by
now. And you usually have
a high RDW, high red
cell distribution width.
Sometimes you have a
thrombocytosis count because
as the bone marrow is
******* up to make more red
cells, sometimes other
parts of the factory kind of
go up as well a little
bit, okay? It's not to the
point where the platelet
count is super, super high
that you're worried, right?
And again, you usually
have a low ferritin because
that's a good measure
of the store of iron,
okay? But always remember,
ferritin is a two-phase
reactant, so if they happen
to be sick in the hospital
and you do a ferritin
level, it might be abnormally
high because it went up
because they were ill.
You usually want to do a
ferritin level when
everything's kind of calmed out.
And these are some of
the other classic iron
things that you look
for, but these are
much more classic and
the low ferritin. Okay.
All right. So what do you
do? The biggest thing is, you
know, is you want to get
this chubby kid who's just
drinking tons of milk all the
time. You see them, they'll
come to the office and
they just always like just
chucking a bottle and they
won't let it go. All right.
And you have to tell the
parents like they have
to cut down on the milk
and obviously increase
iron rich foods. The
main differential is
thalassemia, which I won't
talk about because it's a
huge topic, but very
commonly thalassemia trait,
obviously not thalassemia
major, which can have
significant problems
with their bone marrow.
They have abnormal faces.
They have hepatosmenomygaly.
So that's a major thing,
right? We're talking about
thalassemia trait where
they're basically asymptomatic,
but they're obviously
chronically anemic. and it's
a microcytic type of anemia,
okay? And of course, lead
poisoning, you always, most
of the time when they're
young, you're going to be
screening. When you see
anemia, you also want to
screen for lead as well, all
right? So this is a little
table and when do you expect
the hemoglobin to go up?
So usually once you give,
once the factory, now you
have the supplies to make
red cells coming in, right?
The trucks are all of a
sudden bringing in all the
substrate, the iron, right?
to make now the body has
enough stuff to make red
cells, right? So what's going
to happen is that all of
a sudden a sigma goes
on. It's like, all right,
let's turn up this factory.
Let's start producing. Let's
start producing red cells.
What does that mean? So
after a few days, your
reticulocyte count goes up.
After a month of the factory
working hard, after
about a month,
you have enough, your
stores are, not your stores,
but you have enough
hemoglobin in your body again,
right? So your hemoglobin
goes to normal levels. but
the stores are not enough
right so you have enough for
the the use in the body
right so i always say um the
refrigerator versus
the pantry right so the
refrigerator is is full now
so every time you want to your
body needs is hungry you
open the refrigerator there's
there's uh hemoglobin
enough right enough food
there right but it takes a
while before the pantry can
get full right so you go
shopping, you go shopping
enough that there's food in
the refrigerator, but you
have to keep on going
shopping over the course of
like two, three months
before the overflow can, you
know, fill up your pantry,
which is the body stores.
Okay. So that's why you
always want to tell kids or
parents to give iron for a
good two to three months.
And it's a tough sell
because iron tastes *****. It
can make you constipated.
It has a metallic taste.
No one likes it. So you
really have to have to uh be
beyond them okay so again
there's a little slide on
thalassemia um i'm not
going to go into it you know
there's uh uh that's fine
all right all right and
there's a picture of thou
major uh with the the bone
mouth expansion because
the the body is uh is the
whole they need to recruit
the whole body to produce uh
to produce uh the red cells
right and so what happens
that the bone actually
starts pushing out in the
face, and you have
hepatospinomegaly as well, okay?
Luckily, I've never seen
a case of Thalmajor,
but obviously it's
well-known, and they're
starting to have
treatments for it, okay?
Similar treatments to
sickle cell anemia, genetic
treatments these days, okay?
So obviously, you guys know
the genetics where the
glutamine, which is hydrophilic,
is replaced with valine,
which is hyperphobic,
changes its polarity. Now
it goes from a soft, cushy
red cell that can squeeze
in and out of blood vessels.
Now, under the right
conditions or bad conditions,
such as low oxygen tension,
it can sickle and cause
problems. And what happens
is that it can get stuck.
Luckily, we have
newborn screen.
So a lot of times we
pick these children up
when they're babies before
they're symptomatic,
before they're symptomatic,
confirmed with a
hemoglobin electrophoresis.
and then blood smear,
you can commonly find
sickle, sickled cells,
target cells, and how
old jolly bodies, which
is associated with the
spleen not working right.
So what is the common
feature is things happen
right around three to
six months when the
fetal hemoglobin goes
away. That's important.
Fetal hemoglobin is
very protective, okay?
So once it starts dropping,
right, three to six months,
that's when the symptoms
start happening, right?
these are all the
different crises that will
happen I'm going to go
over some of the more
life-threatening or
dangerous ones that you
really have to know but
it's important to know
pain is a big time
problem I'll talk about
acute chest you can
definitely have strokes
just like those sickles
can get stuck anywhere
it can definitely get
stuck in your brain as
well and cause a ******
and those kids need
chronic transfusions to
keep the sickle level
down Because, I mean, of
all the complications,
you know, having a ******
or having infarction
in the brain could be
one of the worst, okay?
Dactylitis, we'll talk about.
Avascular necrosis
of the femoral head.
Priapism, right? So
that could be a problem,
right? If you have an
******** for way too long,
bad.
All right, so most common
first symptom you're going
to see in kids is usually
this one. Sometimes
you have to warn them that
the hand looks swollen,
red. It looks like it's
actually infected, and it's
hot, right? And this baby
is crying because it hurts
so much. So it's what we
call dactylitis, okay?
And it's a vaso-occlusive
problem. So what do you
want to do? You want to
hydrate them. You want to
pump up the body, make the
conditions more favorable
so the blood won't sickle,
okay? Pain control, all
right? Give oxygen because
a low-oxygen environment
sometimes can be it. If
you think there could be an
infection, any signs of
fever, you want to treat
that, okay? And, of course,
watch for complications.
So what's one complication?
Acute chest crisis.
Basically, your body
can get pneumonia,
and pneumonia can cause what?
Low oxygen. What's
going to happen
with low oxygen? More
sickling happens.
So you go into like
a death spiral.
Literally could lead to
death, which is why you
have to be aware of it.
So all these kids with
sickles, they're coughing,
they have a fever,
they're always going to
get a chest x-ray. If
you see an infiltrate
on any child with sickle
cell disease, you are
definitely going to ICU.
We're going to give you tons
of fluid, take care of the
pain, and definitely give
you IB antibiotics because
we worry we need to decrease
sickling and we need to
take care of the infection
because you can die, right?
This downward spiral, you
have to break that spiral,
okay? And sometimes you get
to a point where you might
need to exchange transfusion.
I've never seen that
needed because these days
our medical care is so good.
But it is there if you
need to, which is not
a simple thing to do in
exchange transfusion.
Next thing you always
think, sickle cell, the
biggest, actually the much
more common problem is that
they can get sepsis. Why?
Because this spleen, after
a while, all those insults
with the sickle cells
cutting into the spleen,
after a while, the spleen
stops working. So they're
functionally asplenic.
Spleen doesn't work by a
very young time of age. And
the spleen has an important
immune function. So they're
definitely at risk for
certain pathogens, the
encapsulated bacteria,
basically. So that's always a big
test question until the end
of time. So you stop taking
bores, you always have to
know spleen's affected,
encapsulated bacteria are
at risk, okay? And these
are the most common
encapsulated bacteria that you
have to know about. Strep
pneumo, H-flu, type B,
Neisseria, and
Salmonella, okay?
All right, so you think
of fever, you have to, any
fever, or you think it could
be sepsis, antibiotics,
don't even think about
it, okay? You don't
hold back with these
kids, all right?
Accused of splitting
crisis. So the
spleen, before it
gets auto-infarcted,
sometimes blood can get
in and it starts causing
an outflow tract problem,
right? It's almost
like a stuck drain. So
what's going to happen?
Blood's going to keep on
pooling and pooling through
the spleen and the spleen
just keeps on enlarging. So
basically all the blood
volume starts getting taken
up by the spleen, leaving
not enough blood for the
body and so you can go into
basically hypovolemic shock,
right? So what's going to
happen is that you have
to be aware. These kids,
obviously, you're going to
have hypovolemic shock.
You're going to look horrible,
maybe pale.
Your heart function is
very poor. You might
have low oxygen as well.
It's being very fast.
And the big thing is that you
have to do a good physical
exam and feel the spleen,
right? So that's why
when you truly are worried
about splenomegaly, you have
to start your palpation
down here and you just keep
on working your way up
and seeing if you can feel
the tip of the spleen okay
uh yeah i mean this is
obviously very very big um
and then you get to the point
where you get to rib cage
and then uh have them take
a deep breath and see if you
can feel you should never
actually feel the tip feel
the spleen okay but if
you started here you just
put your hand right here
you might feel that oh this
is all normal right But
really, you're actually on
top of the spleen. You didn't
feel the edge of it, which
is what you're feeling.
Another type of crisis is an
aplastic sickle cell crisis.
And what happens is
that sickle cell anemia,
the factory has to be
working all the time,
working hard to keep
up with its losses.
These sickled cells are
being broken down pretty
quickly. right? They don't
last 120 days like regular
red cells. So what's going
to happen is that you
need the factory to work
really hard just to keep
up with its losses. So what
happens if your factory
shuts down, right? The
sickle cells are still
there. The sickle red cells
are still there and they're
breaking down pretty
quickly. So what happens if
hemoglobin drops really
quickly, okay? So anything
that makes the factory
shut down or slow down,
most classically, parvovirus
B19 infection is famous
for coming into the bone
marrow and shutting down
and causing problems and
shutting it down, right?
So what happens is that you
can get really bad anemia
very quickly. So in most
kids with sickle cell
disease, you almost
always should have a high
reticulose count. The
factory should be working
hard all the time. That's
expected. In us that
don't have sickle cell
disease, if you did my
reticulocyte count, it
should be normal, all right?
But if I had sickle
cell disease, it would
be high, and that would
be expected. If I got
lab work and the
reticulocyte count was low,
then I'd be very, very
worried. So that is abnormal.
And in those cases,
you want to give tons
of fluids, be on the
lookout for severe anemia,
and if you have to get
the red cells ready for
transfusion, you want
to get it ready, okay?
Again, once again, my bad.
I was going to put a picture
of a World War II factory.
Because why? The analogy
was during that time
in World War II, the factory
was working overtime.
So even though we were
losing tons of tanks,
boats, ships, you know,
the way we did it was
just we just mass produced
everything. And even
though boats were being
sunk in the ocean with
submarines, it doesn't
matter. We just overwhelmed
the system to keep up
production, right? But what
if for some reason oil
factories shut down in
America? We wouldn't
have won, right? We would
not have been able to help
win the war in Europe.
I don't know if
it's a good analogy,
but that's what I came up with.
All right, what's the
management? Big things,
antibiotics,
right?
If there's a fever,
prophylactic antibiotics is very
commonly given, prophylactic
penicillin. Why? Because
you're protecting against
encapsulated bacteria.
Proper immunizations,
and there's a different
immunization schedule. I'm
not going to get into it with
sickle cell or any kids
that have a splenic problem.
Hydration, pain control,
all right?
Hydroxyurea helps raise the
fetal hemoglobin. What did
I say? Fetal hemoglobin
is protective. So if you
raise it a little bit, you
might help out a little bit,
right? Anytime you have a
lot of, you have hemolysis,
you want to give some folic
acid, you know, stem cell
transplant, which is not
available to everyone, and
it's difficult, but can be
curative. And these days,
relatively new last few years,
is that the gene editing
with CRISPR, right? And
what happens that you gene
edit to create a condition
where there's increased fetal
hemoglobin in the body of
these children with sickle
cell disease. And what
happens? The fetal hemoglobin
becomes protective and they
have less crises, okay?
Splitting palpation.
So you actually have to
teach the parents about
how to help with the
spleen so that they're
aware of splitting crisis.
Obviously, education, okay?
All right, let's move on
to bleeding issues. So
there's a coagulation cascade,
just for your reference.
and one pediatric condition
you should know about is
hemorrhagic disease of the
newborn. So it's a known
condition that babies are
relatively low on potassium for
various, various reasons
for placenta transfer, a
sterile gut and bacteria
actually produces vitamin K,
immature livers. Maybe mom was
on certain medications that
cause a problem with vitamin
K and making it lower.
But overall, we know this
condition can happen. And if
you have low vitamin K,
you're at risk for bleeding.
Okay. So what do we do? We
give vitamin K injections,
right? So we give vitamin
K injections at birth.
And a lot of times, this
is not even an issue
in really in the westernized
country, because we
know that. So the only
time you see it is in
other countries that they
don't have the health
care we have, so they
will, you will encounter
some babies with hemorrhage
disease and newborn,
or if they're born outside
the hospital system,
don't seek medical care,
stay at home, which in parts
of America, people don't
trust or don't have the
money for access care, they
stay at home, they give birth,
they stay at home, okay,
and that child is at risk,
okay, and so classic things
that they're going to show
signs of bleeding at birth,
okay? So it could be from
circumcision, could be from
the GI tract, you see blood
in the stool, could be
from the umbilicus. And sometimes
they present with actually
a bleeding in the brain,
usually happens a little
bit later, but that's
obviously the worst condition.
So they might have bulging
fontanelles, be very, very
cranky. And you worry that,
and if they were born outside,
you're worried that they
have bleeding in the brain,
right? And the labs you
would find is a prolonged PT
in this case, so not PTT,
a prolonged PT, all right?
All right, so here
we have a case.
You can read it on your
own, but in the end,
it turns out to be a
three-year-old boy,
has a rash, but seems to be
okay otherwise, all right?
Maybe bruising a little
bit more easily, had
a nosebleed, so rash.
So it depends on what
kind of rash. It could
be anything, right? It
could be highs, whatever.
But when you're on
exam, you know that
it's macular, it's flat,
scattered, it's all
over, non-blanching.
So when you press
on it, it doesn't go
away. So most rashes
are blanching, right?
But certain rashes are
not blanching. One rash
that isn't blanching is
petechiae. So petechiae is
associated with
thrombocytopenia. So your
platelets are very low. So
normal would be 150,000 to
450,000. So here we have
20,000. So it's very
low, and that's why they're
having this bleeding
problem or these petechiae.
Okay, so what is it?
All right, here's a picture
of petechiae and purpura.
Purpura is similar to
petechiae, just more of a
bigger form, all right? And
what it is, we're dealing
with this ITP. So the
classic ITP is a child who
is otherwise normal, and
you do a CBC and only
to play this low. Again,
the factory is working well,
except that one part,
instead of the red cell,
that's working. It's
the platelet part that's
not working well, okay?
And really what it is,
is that it's actually
not a problem with the
factory. It's more of a
problem of destruction,
all right? So the platelets,
the body recognizes
the platelets as a problem.
You have these anti
-platelet autoantibodies,
and this anti-GP2B and 3A
antibody connects to the
platelet. Now, Now, the
splenic macrophage
recognizes this as foreign
and destroys it in the
spleen. And what happens is
that it's really not a
problem with the factory.
It's more like the
minute it leaves
the factory, it's
being destroyed.
And so that's why
it's an immune
thrombotic cytopenic
purpura. Okay.
So classic thing is,
like we mentioned,
petechiae, purpura, mucosal
bleeding. So anytime
you have platelets, you
think of mucosal bleeding.
What's mucosal bleeding?
GI tract, nose,
mouth,
okay? And sometimes under
severe conditions. The
thing we worry about most
is the brain. So these
kids, a lot of times with
IDP, it's really young
kids. They're like two,
three years of age. And
what happens with two,
three years in? They fall,
they climb, you know, and
they jump off the sofa
and they hit their head.
It's very common. They
usually don't get hurt.
But if they have a very low
platelets, you watch, you
worry about them, okay?
And the most common treatment
we actually see, you can
observe, but most people
these days, you know, it's
hard for us to observe when
the child has rash and low
platelet. A lot of times
we'll be giving IBIG to try to
take care of all those
antibodies floating around
that's causing a lot of problems.
You can give corticosteroids
as well. It gives a
transient rise in platelets.
Immune therapy.
Under severe conditions,
you can actually cut out
the spleen through a
splenectomy. If you cut out the
spleen, even though the
antibodies are attached,
the spleen won't go in and
destroy it, so you'll get
a rise. But you remove
the spleen, what happens?
You are at risk
for encapsulated
bacteria and
sepsis. Sepsis, bad.
Most times, ITP, transient.
But in general, you
don't want to play
with transfusions.
Why? Because it's
just going to be
destroyed anyway.
So let's move on to
another bleeding problem,
hemophilia.
I think you guys
should know by now.
Hemophilia A is
factor VIII, which is
much more common.
hemophilia B, factor 9,
X-length recessive, so usually
we're dealing with nails, okay?
All right, and the most
common reason you get it,
and this is exactly how
I've had a couple of cases,
is that baby gets
circumcised, and then
the OB complains like,
man, this baby would
not stop bleeding,
no matter how much
packing, tried it,
would not stop bleeding,
you know, I had OB once
that had to go back
in because when it
stopped bleeding, they had
to like stitch the
area closed to stop it.
Once that happens, you
think that you might be
dealing with hemophilia,
okay? So that's a very
classic and you make diagnosis
when they're younger,
okay? Sometimes you make
diagnosis when they're
older if the factor levels
are not that low, okay?
So, and the classic thing
is hemoarthrosis. So
swelling in the joints,
swelling is really blood in the
joints right so for very
minor trauma right we fall
we hit our elbows we hit
our knees especially uh
and uh even even little
cuts so once i had uh it
wasn't my patient but i had
an attending i heard the
pay attending talking to
a patient on the phone uh
when i was a resident and
um the patient called and
says hey uh you know the
child got a small cut He
fell and he got a small
cut. He looks fine, but the
cut won't stop bleeding.
And it was a very, they
said it was a very small
cut. The doctor said, no,
come in. You got to come
in and get factor, right?
Because that little cut,
even though it's nothing for
us, we just kind of put
pressure, put a band-aid.
That little cut will
keep on bleeding,
bleeding, bleeding,
bleeding, bleeding.
And, you know, this attending
knew this child's case
and knew that this child
has very, very low factors
in general. And one thing,
remember, I always want
to learn about things that
can kill you and things that
you should be aware of,
right? So the iliopsoas
muscle, just like the
spleen in sickle cell, can
accumulate blood, right? For
some reason, it can accumulate
a large volume of blood
and lead to hemorrhagic
shock. Same principle as
sickle cell splenic crisis,
okay? And it can manifest
as vague groin pain. So, bay
groin pain in a hemophiliac,
you want to be careful.
Watch out. Could there be
internal bleeding? Okay.
And again, this is not a
platelet issue. So, the petechia
is uncommon, right? So,
this is classic deformed.
I mean, there might
be blood in there, but
over time, these
hemophiliacs, they bleed
in the joint all the
time, and those blood
products get reabsorbed,
and it just creates
a distorted dysfunctional
joint. and it
can be a main
problem, big problem,
okay? And the big
thing you should know
is in this case, the PTT
is prolonged because in
the clotting cascade is the
intrinsic problem, okay?
You don't have to
know this, but a lot
of times the symptom
pathology depends
on how much factor
they have, right?
In their body. And again,
dealing with genetics,
there's different levels.
Some kids are very, very mild
And some kids have almost
no factor What you want to
do is give them a factor
We have recombinant factor
replacement And that's
usually what you need to do
Pretty simple Obviously,
it's not the general
pediatrician Taking
care of this It's a
hematologist taking
care of it You can give
desmopressin as well
Because it's related
It's a treatment in Von
Willebrand disease Which we'll
talk about And what happens
it promotes factor VIII
release. And so if we're
dealing with hemophilia A, which
is factor VIII, this might
help a little bit, okay?
And there's immunological
modalities these days,
and of course, supportive
care and prevention,
right? You want to be
careful with these kids.
The joints get messed up
from the cyclic
hemoarthrosis, right?
All right, so we'll talk
about, I think this is the
last blood issue we're
going to talk about is von
Willebrand's disease. It's
autosomal dominant. So it's a
very common bleeding disorder,
but it's because it's
very, very mild and it's
not as flashy as hemophilia.
A lot of people forget
about it, right?
But what it is is
that it can cause
bleeding like mucus
cutaneous bleeding,
but not from thrombocytopenia.
And again, a lot of times
it's picked up because
they had a surgery. They
went to the dentist, got
a tooth pulled or whatever,
got dental work done.
And you know how we
sometimes just even from a
cleaning get a little blood
in your mouth? So these
kids or adults, they bleed
a lot more than that,
right? And that's when
sometimes you have a
first clue that maybe
there's a bleeding problem.
And for me, who's
a pediatrician,
see a lot of teenagers,
right? The one most common
one is a teenager with
excessive menstrual bleeding.
So I had one girl who's
very anemic, had extremely
heavy periods, right?
No matter what we did, could
not slow it down, right?
So we checked her for Von
Willebrand disease, right?
So it was on your
differential, let's check it.
It actually came back
normal, right? But you read
the books, you realize
that, you know, the test
that you ordered for
Von Willebrand antigen,
resucitin cofactor, factor
VIII level, the screening
test is not always reliable.
I think in her case,
the von Willeban antigen
resucitin cofactor was normal,
but the factor VIII was
like a little bit low, all
right? And so, you know,
being a good doctor, I happen
to know that the screening
test is not always reliable.
So a few months later, I
sent it again. And when
I sent again, it was low.
It was now definitively, it
was low. She has Von Willow
-Brandt's disease. Okay.
And so we treated her
as such, right. So gave
her DDAVP. And, you
know, obviously I didn't
handle this. This moved
on to subspecialist care.
Pediatric hematologist was
taking care of the rest
of it. And, you know, whenever
she went to dentist or
had surgery, they would,
they would give her DVADP
to help her, okay? And one
thing you always remember,
remember it's the factor
eight, is the von Willebrand
factor is always their
best friends, okay? Von
Willebrand factor and factor
eight, they're tight with
each other. They like
each other, okay? In fact,
von Willebrand likes to
protect factor eight, almost
like a big brother, big
sister, okay? So, and really
that's how the relationship
works, okay? And the
reason they have mucosal
bleeding is that von Willebrand
factor aids in platelet
adhesion. So even though
the platelets are normal,
it acts like a low platelet
situation. Okay, so let's
move on to oncology now.
And again, a lot of
problems that can happen in
oncology. Luckily, it's
very, very rare. I've seen a
very, very small handful of
children that had to deal
with these things.
Obviously, it's a very, very
stressful situation. and
it takes a very special
person to do pediatric
oncology to be truthful, okay?
Luckily, we have a
lot of good outcomes
and especially if
caught early, all right?
So that's really the
big key is being aware
of those red flags that
if you're not sure,
you've got to work them
up and or send them
off for a workup,
okay? So there's some
epidemiology and basically
these conditions here,
ALL, neuroblastomerular
tumor, happen more when
they're younger, okay,
more when they're younger,
and a lot of these
sarcomas, osteosarcomas,
Mejuni sarcomas,
Hodgkin's, all right,
it happens, you're
thinking about
older, a little bit
older kids, okay.
So acute leukemia, I know
you got a huge lecture
on leukemias, and it's
probably more extensive
what I'm going to go
through. obviously ALL is the
much more common leukemia
and the B lymphoblastic
is common, most more
common than that. Okay.
And again,
very young,
we're dealing with young
kids, right? So the couple
of children that I was been
involved in the initial
diagnosis, you know, you take
care of kids when they've
already diagnosed and,
you know, they're on the
floor and you have to take
care of them, but the initial
diagnosis, you know,
both of them happen to be
like under two years of age.
So it's quite devastating
when you make the diagnosis,
okay? But luckily,
usually you have really good
outcomes, thank God, okay?
So when you suspect leukemia,
basically red flags,
right? Think of the red
flags, fever, not looking
well, fatigue, malaise, don't
want to play, the limping
pallor petechiae signs that
the factory is not working
right persistent infections
or neutropenia right so
you get all these things
through a cbc it's quick
it's easy it's cheap i know
kids don't like to get blood
work done i don't like
to order blood work but
sometimes you just got to
do what you got to do and of
course you see anything
like significant like lymph
adenopathy hepatosplenomygaly
so you got to check for
these things or um you know
a weird rash like like a
blueberry muffin appearance
in AML, neurological issues,
right? Obviously, you have
all these things here.
You have to have more higher
index suspension, okay?
How do you make diagnosis?
You get the lab work.
You do fancy lab testing.
I'm not going to go into
it. I put it here more for
your refresh your memory,
some of the common things
that are tested, especially
in your level ones.
and yeah, you do a CBC
and a bone marrow you see the
blast, you see the abnormal
low platelets, low
red cells white cells
can be very very low
or very very high
what do you do?
we're not going
to go too much in
treatment they keep
on changing, they keep
on refining these
regimens, it's great
a lot of research and
money is poured in and
that's one reason why we
have good outcomes So I'm
not expecting you to
know it. Just understand
that sometimes you have
to give intrathecal
chemotherapy. When you give
chemotherapy, it can cause
problems with all the
cells breaking up and
having tumor lysis syndrome.
You can get relapses.
Stem cell transplant is a
possibility as well. And
the big thing is infection.
Okay, so my patient that
I diagnosed when she was
around 15, 18 months, came
in, just looked like a cold,
didn't look like anything,
you know, saw her, she
was cranky, but it wasn't
for a very long time. um
and um yeah i was going to
send the child home with
a you know just a virus
there's no antibiotic needed
uh and just when i was i
think i went to go get a
book because in the clinic we
always give a book to the
infants uh when they leave
and i went to go get a book
and when i came back uh
and she was crying right
she was very unhappy i just
noticed that she all of
a sudden started having
petechia like in front of
my eyes petechia under uh
head started appearing and
i looked um and it started
appearing in the body as well
so just like just probably
from her crying and causing
all the pressure and
just um she was like on
the verge and you know uh
the fact that she's sick
and petechia made me think
one of the other cause of
petechia is actually sepsis
meningococcemia sent her to
the ER to get her worked up
and her CBC came
out super abnormal
her white count
was in the hundreds
immediately they suspected
this could be ALL,
sent them off to a
children's hospital and got
treated and for a few
years she did well she
went to remission, did
well and unfortunately
one day she just got a
fever and she got septic
and passed away So it
was very, very sad.
All right, so these
are complications.
Again, white counts can be so
high, they can cause draw by.
You can get DIC.
All the cells breaking
up can affect the kidney,
right?
The electrolytes being
abnormal, you learn cardio.
the potassium being too high
or too low, you realize,
in this case, too high
from all the cell products,
can cause cardiac arrhythmias.
And hypocalcemia can
cause neurological seizures.
So it's a very dangerous
situation when they're
first being treated to be
aware of this. And the truth
is, human oncologists are
well aware of this situation,
and they're looking out
for it. And these days,
they can cause problems,
but you rarely see a child
doing very poorly from it.
But this thing, again,
I mentioned, infection
is a very, very serious
risk. And a lot of these
hematologic oncology
things, it's this issue.
And depending on the issue, you
can have compression syndrome.
So I'm not going to get
into that. That's a whole
other thing. All right.
So let's move. Let's move
forward. And we have a kid
that's not acting right.
Dark circles, walking
unsteady. So she's a
toxic, right? You do an
exam, her arms and legs
are moving around, eyes
darting around. She just
doesn't look right.
Again, red flags. Okay.
More red flags in history.
So you know enough
to ask about fevers.
You look at the growth
chart, she's been losing
weight. She's cranky,
maybe having some
bone pains. She's only
three, but she does seem
to say her bones hurt.
And then you do a good
exam and you feel an
abdominal mass. So
what's going on, okay? So
what she has is a
very classic situation
called neuroblastoma,
right? So it's a tumor.
You can have these
dark circles on her
eyes, which is a
sign of metastasis.
Proptosis is actually
the eye can be
pushed out because the
tumor is in the back
of the eye at this
point, all right?
Most of them are diagnosed
when they're young, again,
and this condition, because
it can metastasize and
be difficult to take care
of, sometimes cannot end
well, right? And I had
the situation, it wasn't
my patient, but it was a
private doctor's patient
was on, basically, this
is years ago when hospice
wasn't that common for
pediatric patients. And they
came into the hospital
pretty much to pass away.
And it was because the
neuroblastoma, there was
nothing else we could do
at this point. So we just
wanted to make the child
comfortable. Okay, and
basically, the neuroblastoma
is the neural part,
right? So that's kind
of like for you guys to
always think it's a
blastoma, it's a cancer,
but it has neurological
problems, right?
Because why? Because
this can happen anywhere
there's sympathetic
tissue, the tumor can grow.
Most commonly, it grows
in the adrenals, and so it
can present as abdominal
mass, but it can go anywhere,
right? It can go in the
cervical spine, paracervical,
and wherever it goes, it
can cause compression in
those issues. In the thorax,
cause vena cava syndrome,
respiratory stress
stridor, right?
But the most common one
is abdominal mass, okay?
And the presentation,
what I described of
this child not acting
right and the eyes looking
right is this
obsequinous, myoclonous,
ataxia syndrome, right?
So they have dancing
eyes, dancing feet.
It's not working right.
And what it is, is the
neurological part is being
disrupted. And why? Because
this tumor is special.
This is special because
it has catecholamine
metabolites. And a
catecholamine in the body,
almost like a
phyocromocytoma, causes all
sorts of wacky conditions.
right? And so what
you wanted, it can
cause severe diarrhea,
it can cause sweating
or hypertension, right?
Catecholomies. So we
had a patient once,
this is again when
I was a resident,
came in, now didn't
have a lot of red
flags, was about
maybe three years
old, right around
that young age group.
She looked okay. But
for the last, you know,
several days to a week, she
wasn't walking right she
was ataxic right maybe there
was a history of a of a
prior code here and there
was admitted neurology came
did a brief workup diagnosed
the most common reason
is cerebellar ataxia right
so the virus can kind of
kind of like um uh get
into your system your your
neurological system and cause
wreak a little havoc and they
usually recover over time
so most likely that's
probably what it was didn't
do tons of imaging uh and uh
child didn't look too too
bad at all but definitely
when i remember walking
this child around the uh the
floor and this child was
like you know like you could
tell that was like huh that
was not good um but the
neurologist knowing the
differential of ataxia said
hey before she goes home
because we're not going to keep
her in the hospital until
she stops walking funny.
She wasn't in any
distress. They
sent the urine for HVA and VMA,
homovanillic acid and
vanillamandelic acid.
But these labs take a
little while to come back.
So what happened?
We got the lab
work, got the urine,
sent the child home.
A week later,
neurology calls us and says,
gives us the update that
labs came back abnormal
that we have to repeat it
the urine hba and vma came
back abnormal so all of
a sudden like oh my god
like really like surprising
right you just see these in
textbooks and that's what
happened called the
patient patient in between
discharge from from our
hospital over the next several
days was started to do worse
and went to actually went
to another hospital. And
from there, they were able
to make diagnosis. So
they got an x-ray of the
abdomen and chest and workup.
I think they probably did
a CT of the brain. And
I think that they found
abdominal mass. So it turned
out to be a neuroblastoma.
Lost follow-up.
I don't know what
the follow-up was in this case.
Hopefully, she was fine.
So abdominal mass, usually
think of two things.
You think of Wilms'
tumor and neuroblastoma.
Wilms' tumor acts
very, very different.
Wilms' tumor just
acts as a big mass. So
the Wilms' tumor just...
A few more minutes.
Thank you.
Sorry, I'm at a conference
recording this lecture
and they want to clean up
the room. So, all right.
So, Wilma's tumor usually
presents as just an asymptomatic
abdominal mass, just
noted, and it doesn't have
all those neurological
conditions, right? So, usually,
you just find the mass.
They usually don't have
too many other issues. I
wrote here, because in the
textbooks, they might have
abdominal pain. You think
about a big abdominal mass,
it might press on things.
It's in the kidney,
right? It's a renal mass.
So it can technically
cause hematuria, all right?
And it's relatively common.
I've seen a few cases of these.
And again, young kids,
right, young kids,
all right? And
this is the classic
hallmark. It's written
in all the textbook.
Asymptomatic abdominal
mass incidentally
found by the parent, you know,
textbooks say when
they're taking a bath, you
know, you're washing them,
and with soap, they're
smooth, and you can feel
the mass. or during an
abdominal exam when they
come in for a physical,
you know, part of the exam
is always checking the
abdomen and sometimes you can
feel the mass there, okay?
And then, you know, the
treatment is you want to cut
out the mass, chemotherapy,
radiation. And this
patient, I have pictures,
not a picture of my patient,
but it looks very,
very similar.
It has a really huge mass.
Actually, the patient came
in with wheezing, had a
history of asthma. We treated
the child as such, like,
and the child is really sick.
I remember so sick that,
you know, the treatments
didn't seem to be working.
OSOX was low,
breathing really fast.
And the mass we felt,
and I was on that day, I
felt like that was abnormal.
There was definitely
something there, but I
thought it was the liver.
I thought it was the
hepatomegaly I was feeling.
And the child also had
a murmur at that time.
So murmur,
trouble breathing,
hepatomegaly, you should
actually, you guys
didn't do cardio yet,
but that's actually
a sign of like
congestive heart failure
situation. So we actually
call cardio, cardio.
Cardio came to do
echocardiogram. We
told them two kids
really, really sick,
came in immediately, did
echocardiogram. Heart
was fine, but while
evaluating the mass, because
the doctor, the
cardiologist could feel it,
put a sonogram probe to
that, and they realized,
whoa, this is not a
liver. This is a solid
mass, solid tumor. And
from there, we realize,
oh, we're dealing with
something completely
different, transferred
off to a specialty care
hospital to take care of
it. And we got a report
later, it turned out to
be a womb's tumor, okay?
All right, so this is a
normal child with a normal
red reflex, okay? This is
a child with an absent red
reflex on the left side,
right? In this case, it
looks actually a little
white, right? So this is a
classic situation of a
retinoblastoma. And this is why
we always are obsessed, if
pediatricians are obsessed
about doing red reflexes
on kids all the time.
This classic gene.
So there is a genetic
component that
can happen. So it
can run in families.
And the classic thing is an
abnormal red reflex or what
be leukocoria is a white
reflex. It looks like a
cat's eye. It looks like it's
glowing. You know, cats in
the dark, if you shine a
light in their eye, it almost
looks like it's glowing.
And sometimes they have
strabismus where it's misaligned,
their eyes are misaligned
or darting around, okay?
And what it is is because,
and this is a patient I saw
in the clinic, is that, I
mean, even without the
ophthalmoscope, you could see
there was something wrong
with this kid's eye. You can
almost see the white reflex
without the ophthalmoscope.
I didn't have to shine a
light this eye was just
glowing white and it was
darting all around and what it
is the tumor grew so big
that the eye was trying to
find trying to find the
image and it was just darting
around um and it was it was
pretty obvious that you know
this child obviously has to
go to um the ophthalmologist
stat immediately and um
and um and turned out yes
that's what it was she had
a retinoblastoma. So anytime
you have an abnormal,
you have a suspicion that
the eye is funny, it's better
to refer to eye doctor and
just get it checked out.
And there's been cases where
I couldn't get a good red
reflex for whatever reason.
Sometimes darker skin
kids, their retina is also
darker and the retina is
also darker. You don't get a
really crisp red reflex. And
so sometimes those cases,
I'll send them to ophthalmology,
turns out to be fine.
I'm just a nervous pediatrician
it's all good okay um
you know there's a histology
like a lot of them there's
this uh blue cell tumor with
rosette formation that's
for your own board studying
in the future all right
and what happens you're
trying to treat them and these
days you know there's been
more and more successes
over the years where you
actually treat them and save
the eye but there's a lot
of cases especially in the
past back when i trained uh
where you couldn't save the
eye you had to try to before
the tumor spread um and
metastasize uh you would
just take the whole eye out
and put a prosthesis in right
and that's what happened
with this this girl we had
it was it was too far gone
they tried and uh they
couldn't do it couldn't save
the eye and um got it taken
out and um they was turned
out to be a genetic issue
component because Now, her
younger sister had to get
routine eye exams very, very
commonly because they
realized she carried the gene,
okay?
Last two conditions are
bone tumors. So bone tumors,
you think of a Ewing
sarcoma, and the other one
is osteosarcoma, okay?
So the Ewing sarcoma, the
one thing to think about
is that the Ewing sarcoma
has more systemic symptoms.
So those red flags,
U.S. sarcoma can't
have it, okay?
This is the genetics.
I think from what
I read, it's very
common. Back in
the day, I had to
memorize this gene
for this condition.
So again, you can get,
and this one is very
aggressive because you
can have early metastasis.
And we all know early
metastasis, bad, right?
And sometimes they can
present with pathologic
fractures, right? They
were playing a sport.
When they're playing a
sport, who doesn't fall,
get hit by someone
else, and they have bone
pain. But again, persistent
bone pain. And in this
case, with red flags,
you want to work it up.
And when you work it up,
do an x-ray. You might
see this onion skinning
or layers of swelling.
Layers of swelling
like an onion.
and what it is, areosteal
reaction in sequence causing
a layering effect, right?
This is not the best picture
to see it, but it's what
I can find, okay? Again,
these primitive blue round
cells, and again, you treat it
the way you treat it. I'm
not going to go into that.
I'm not an oncologist.
I'm sure it keeps
on changing as
progress occurs, okay?
All right. And osteosarcoma,
the other one is
usually just more of an
isolated bone tumor and
doesn't have those red
flags. Right. But they
will have the red flags
they have is they hurt.
The limb is hurting where
the bone tumor is. Pain,
limb, swelling. Okay. And
swelling. And without, there's
no history, true history
of trauma or anything like
that. Right. So, you know,
in the books, it happens
a little bit more during
the adolescent growth spurt.
Not sure if that's
true or not. In this
case, you just want
to have a high index
suspicion whenever kids
have persistent bone
pain. All right. And
for no other reason.
Okay.
And again, no systemic
signs makes it different
from Ewing's sarcoma.
These are genetics from it.
All right.
And in this case, the
classic finding is a sunburst
pattern, right? Versus
Ewing likes to eat an onion,
right? Patrick Ewing, the
famous Knicks Hall of Famer.
That's how I remembered Patrick
Ewing was eating
an onion, right?
An osteosuncoma. That's
how I remembered, right?
And that's a sunburst
pattern, right? You can
also have Codman's
triangle here. And that's
what it is, the tumor is
causing the periosteum
to lift up. And
when it lifts up, it
creates kind of like a
sail or a triangle, okay?
And what it is, like
you make the diagnosis,
obviously you send
them off, okay?
And what happens a lot of
times, more and more we're
able to save these limbs. but
back in the day once again
just like with the eye a
lot of times you you get
rid of the issue by just cutting
it out before metastasized
and so in order you have
to sacrifice a limb to
save the body all right so
some you know I I knew one
friend when I was younger
that had osteosarcoma And
yeah, he didn't, I think is
under one of his knees, they
had to cut out, cut off
his leg. And it's because
he had osteosarcoma, right?
So, but he lives a normal,
relatively normal, healthy
life otherwise, okay,
which is good. And
osteosarcoma is one claim to
fame is it can happen as
a secondary cancer from
other treatments, especially
with those genetic
syndromes that predispose
you to cancers, okay?
All right, so some questions,
future slides, I'm not
going to flip through them.
There's some questions for
you guys to look at and do.
I know you guys
like doing that.
And there's also, of
course, there's an
evaluation form at the end
of the PowerPoint to fill
out, if you want, to
give me some feedback.
All right. So that's
the end of the lecture.
Took a few minutes over.
But, again, a lot of topics.
Hopefully, the time went
fast, especially if you 1
.5 times me to 2 times me.
All right. So, all right.
Take care. Email me if
you have any questions.
And that's it, all right?
Last thing I'm going to
say, again, this has nothing
to do with the test, is a
lot of people, you know,
when you think of a hemock,
you know, a lot of people
don't want to do P's. So
this is like my little spiel
about pediatric hemock.
It's because they think, you
know, you can never deal
with, how do you deal with
these kids that bad things
happen? And the one thing
I'll say is that luckily
it's pretty rare, all right?
it's pretty rare. And when
it does happen, luckily,
even though I described a
case of one of my patients
didn't doing well, but I
would say it's rare these
days. You know, most times
they have very good care.
It's very specialized care.
People are very caring.
And so bad things can
happen to anyone in any
specialty. And it's very
tragic when it happens
to kids. But luckily,
it's pretty rare. You just
have to be, try to make
the diagnosis, try to
be aware of these situations
as much as you can,
right? And as I say this,
I remember, you know,
what day is today?
Today is, two days
ago I was in clinic.
And, of course, this lecture
I'm recording is on my
mind, right? Because I know
I have to record it. It's
trying to retain the
information in my head. And what
patient walks in is like a
five or six-year-old boy,
and he's complaining of
bone pain, right? He's
complaining of bone pain for
no reason, no systemic signs.
So I'm like,
you know, they brought
this kid into me.
Luckily, I did everything,
asked all the history. So
the bone pain was only for
one or two days, right?
No hepatosplenomegaly.
No lymphadenopathy. And
when I say I checked
this kid over, like, head
to toe, no petechiae.
I went, you know, luckily
this kid was very,
very cooperative, and I
got really good abdominal
exams. Definitely no
hepatosplenomegaly.
No weight loss.
So luckily it's my
patient, so I have a
history of his weight.
And he looks fine, right?
He doesn't look sick.
But he did complain of
pain in that one joint.
And he was limping around
when he was walking.
So I made him walk up
and down the corridor.
And yeah, so what I tell
mom is like, hey, I expect
this to go away in several
days to a week. And if it
doesn't go away Or it gets
worse I 100% want you to
come back And so I didn't
want to do an x-ray at
this point Because why
irradiate Give radiation When
most likely the history was
He was playing at church
Mom wasn't watching him
He probably fell
But we don't know So
there's no history of
trauma But it happened
That day he was at
church They ended up
going to the park and
he was walking and
playing around more. So
it probably aggravated
it. And then by the
time he came to me,
you know, it's probably,
you know, it was
irritated. That's what
I'm hoping, right? So I'm
hoping for good news that,
you know, when I check
in with him next week,
that he'll be completely
fine. He won't be walking
funny anymore. But
if he is, I would start
working him up, okay?
All right, so that was
just a bonus, bonus
waste of five minutes
of your time. And then,
yeah, now it's really
done. This lecture's over.
And good luck. I think
that's it. Take care.